what are some of the other Duos  quarterback wide receiver Duos that you  like think are like top five or up there  trick question and go Pat Mahomes and  Travis Kelsey I I consider him he's uh  he's a he's a receiver you know the way  that they're on the same page all the  time it's it's awesome we got Joe and  Jamar Chase Joe burrow and Jamar Chase I  think Matthew Stafford and Cooper cup  um are up there so that's three probably  Tom and Mike Evans of course help me out  here you know I know it's still early  but I like Jalen hurts and I like AJ  Brown like you know those guys that's a  pretty good Duo you know I like I like  those guys like I don't know man you  know the eagles they going crazy like a  lot of respect to those guys man